you know one of my favorite words in the
English language is the word schmooze my
other favorite word in the English
language in the English language is
schmuck
so stop schmoozing you anyway good
evening tonight
the Academy honors four great artists
each one is a trailblazer in their field
as a studio system faded limb stole
master saw an opportunity as the first
independent casting director in motion
pictures to work directly and intimately
with filmmakers helping realize their
vision and bringing fresh faces to the
screen now
although women had worked in the editing
room from the early days of movies until
anvi Coates came along they were there
purely to follow the instructions of the
director a pretty good idea but not with
an and approached her career with
absolutely no consciousness of gender
inequality
she brought artistic leadership to the
cutting room never for a minute thinking
that she was less than anyone else
frederick wiseman is an unstoppable
groundbreaking filmmaker his penetrating
documentaries contain no narration no
interviews no one speaks directly to the
camera and no explicit agenda yet few
films will hit you with more force than
his films and finally Jackie Chan
the indestructible global crowd-pleaser
who revolutionized the martial arts
genre by bringing an unexpected element
comedy now the four of you are genuine
game changers and we are honored to
share this evening with you
congratulations